Lee what do writers need to know about
writing for television a lot writing for
television it's a corporate job really
in a lot of ways it is a morning tonight
regular in office job granted every
office is different so you're going to
have some rooms where you are in the
room for 40 some-odd weeks you're going
to have some rooms that can mean for
three weeks after which writers go off
to write their own episodes it works
differently with every show some shows
writers from staff writers will end up
on set producing their own episode and
others they loaned it but it is similar
to a corporate structure in that you
rise up in the levels from year to year
if you are writing consistently doing a
good job you're expected to see bumps
from year to year so staff writer to
story edit our story editor to executive
story editor on and on and on
they say that television is
significantly harder to break into but
easier to create a consistent income in
so easier to make a living in on an
ongoing basis film on the other hand is
easier to break into you know but
television really is all about character
theme and world it really is about
exploring those and examining those in
an ongoing basis film tends to be more
plot driven but things like pitching in
the room being able to present ideas in
the room being able to politic properly
within a room in order to promote
yourself all of that comes into play in
the world of television it's highly
competitive therefore highly social you
really have to keep your show on a
relationship your executive producer
relationship and your relationship with
a network if you're working in a network
environment freshen fostered it's really
a 365 day a year job it doesn't have the
freedom of film where you really are
kind of sent off to do your rewrites
even on assignment you are constantly
working in harmony with others and it's
a world where people easily lose their
job get new jobs etc etc so it's a
demanding world it's a growing world
we're seeing you know roughly 40 100 WJ
members collect
, from television per year and I'm not
talking about residuals it's also a high
reward kind of world because as you rise
in the ranks you will get more and more
and more financial reward and it is a
world where you can build a living right
you can buy a house and assume that in
five years you'll unless you really mess
up in some grotesquery you will be able
to maintain a living that said I've seen
writers mess up and grotesque aways and
TV and continue to work once you're in
you're able to sustain a career it's
very tough to break into there are two
paths that are seen as kind of the the
more sure bets to break in in a world
where nothing as certain so those paths
are the television writing programs that
are offered by the network's as well as
a few additional organizations such as
Humanitas Sundance HBO Cape n HMC those
kind of writing programs that foster new
talent that's one way to break in
another way is to go the assistant route
so become a showrunner as assistant can
become a writers assistant to even start
as a PA in the room that said there are
other ways to breaking in the web has
been very helpful we're seeing people
like Issa Rae really make their mark
transitioning from the web to television
of known writers to write web series and
from that get staffed it's highly
competitive but the majority of WGA
sanctioned jobs are in television today
and it's a growing industry what is
shrinking is the size of the room so as
we go into more basic cable and digital
rooms we're seeing those rooms get
smaller so I have writers and network
rooms where I have 18 writers in a room
you're not going to see that on an
Amazon show on a Netflix show on a hulu
show you're going to see significantly
smaller rooms that are very auteur
driven but certainly it is a growing
industry where everybody's looking for
great new voices let's talk about
finding the culture of that room and
respecting the culture and being able to
fit in the culture is different with
every room so you know I had this year I
had one writer in one room that opened
at 11:00 close to three was open for
three weeks and was done
the writers had lunch together everybody
get along it was a bit of a kumbaya you
know I've had writers and rooms that it
was pure tyranny where the showrunner
ruled the room with a heavy hand where
there was a lot of persecution of the
writers who didn't fit in and that's
where I think it's very similar to
corporate structure you can have great
corporate environment and you can have a
poor corporate environment but it really
is about learning your place in that
room so if you're coming in as a staff
writer learning when to pitch when to
sit back when to support when to shut up
what to get involved in what not to get
involved with so of course you have
lists of no-nose you know you don't want
to step on somebody else's pitches you
don't want to write a dead pitch you
don't want to engage in office gossip
you don't want to write anything about
the room on on twitter ever if
especially if it's negative so you have
those things that are the kind of codes
of conduct that said every room is
different so I've seen writers get away
in some things within some rooms where
in another room forget about it you know
but it really is for new writers it is
about finding your place being able to
be useful being able to not melt into
the background and really contribute to
the room from game day one because it's
a kind of job where you have to perform
from the first day there is no learning
curve you don't have the time to ramp up
well it sounds like also you have to
make it work whether I have room with
those but means sometimes you're going
to be there what 15 hours a day with
people absolutely you know comedy rooms
tend to go longer just because things
are funny or at midnight than there are
two o'clock in the afternoon but you do
have to make it work or else you'll be
cut with the first cuts you know nobody
has picked up for a full season for
television so usually you'll get a first
contract with a back number of weeks
right so 10 weeks with a back 10 20
weeks with a back 20 and then the show
will have the right to exercise your
option to bring you back for that extra
set of 20 weeks extra set of nine weeks
whatever it is and that will be
dependent on whether or not they feel
that you are a value they may decide not
to
sighs your option and just let you go
they may opt to not exercise your option
and replace you so you have to be useful
at every step of the way you have to be
productive you have to help others and
prop others up if you want to keep that
job it's in some rooms you get your
episodes and you just focus on that when
you don't have your episode you're done
you sit and wait for your episode
assignment in other rooms you're going
to be at the board or you're going to be
helping out when the writer who's
assigned to an episode is at the board
you're going to board an episode you're
going to break an episode together
you're going to help research so you
really have to make yourself
indispensable to that room what's the
fine line between pleasing the
showrunner but not stepping on the toes
or threatening the other writers in the
room that's where the politicking comes
in right because you want to find your
upper level allies right whether it's
your show runner or the co EP that's
usually the number two in the room you
want to have those allies who are
rooting for you who are fostering you
but you want to remain friendly with
everybody else so you really have to
make sure to not be boastful to not be
arrogant to be grateful for whatever it
is that you have whatever you whatever
responsibility you are given to take
input from others at every juncture at
every moment at every step of the way
because that will continue to ingratiate
you with the other writers that you
ultimately have to rely on and in every
room there is that moment where somebody
can be thrown under the bus and you just
don't want it to be you so you have to
remain in good favor with as many people
in the room as you can okay so let's
take the situation of you are thrown
under the bus how do you keep your
character in good standing and not let
anger come through but still fairly
defend yourself or maybe there's not a
way to do that it's a tough thing to do
and that's why you want to have allies
in upper levels who will stand up for
you because if you're a Staffie who's
thrown under the bus there's only so
much you can do for yourself if you're
able to continue to impress your
showrunner you're number two
there will likely be somebody coming to
your rescue if there's any decency in
the room and that's why you want to
maintain those channels of communication
you know the truth of the matter is you
want to avoid being the person thrown
under the bus to start with and that's
why you want to foster those
relationships on a regular basis well
I'm not throwing anybody else under the
bus because once you're under the bus
it's very very tough to get up from
under in that show you may be able to
resurrect on another show and it's very
very much possible on TV as an industry
where you fail up which is a great
luxury but once you're thrown under the
bus it's a little late so you really
want to proactively instill the
relationships really fortify the
relationships that will put you in a
situation that if you're thrown under
the bus and fired everybody will come in
and apologize to you and that does
happen
you